how is your Bravo Khan going so far
Ramona you know what I appeared on the
panel today with my fellow house mates
are it we're gonna call them cast mates
and it was fun and you know I felt the
energy of the fans and that is
intoxicating and it was really nice to
sit there with Dave Quinn the esses all
these really important questions and you
know what Rob I just say Bravo is such a
wonderful franchise I mean I would I
join them 12 years ago they were just
like a little speck and now they're
bigger than huge and you know God bless
you are in the middle of shooting the
next season no we're almost over really
at four weeks left all right so we're
wrapping things up a season without
Bethenny how does that change the
dynamic you know what it's very
interesting with a cast member leaves it
just keeps going we're a machine but I
have to say this year I really feel this
show is gone to a different level where
we as women may be because where we are
in our lives you know you know we're
empty nesters we're changing careers
we're moving and we have bonded in such
a different way to season than never
before never before in 12 years and
you're gonna see us going deeper about
our feelings and I think we learned in a
really late fans are gonna really relate
all right LuAnn went on Jenny McCarthy
and said you were probably happy
Bethenny was gone because you're afraid
of Bethenny are you afraid of Bethenny I
think I'm the only person to stand up
against Bethenny all the other girls
just kiss her ass do you think she made
a mistake walking away or was it the
right decision
I think Bethenny know
exactly what she's doing she's very
smart woman she hasn't gotten where she
is by not knowing what she's doing in no
I think you know what she there's about
she met him in an I'm a dick goosebumps
and she's believed generally in love
with and he loves her and you know what
she's already established herself in the
reality TV world and her business and
careers and you know it's time now for
her to find true love and I think she's
found it with him and I think it was a
great decision for me I love that we
know there's a new housewife can you
tell me anything about her oh you heard
there's a new housewife well I can't say
anything of the watch the show come
whenever the airs is season 12 but there
is or not
alright well season 13 you might have
another new housewife because your pal
Kelly Dodd engaged to a guy you
introduced her to who lives here in New
York City love Rick and Kelly together
yes Kelly stayed with me she had just
broken up with her boyfriend and I said
come to stay with me she's are you sure
come come come come
she stayed with me for eight days she's
younger than me I have more energy than
her I tracked her from one party to
another and then what party shouldn't
want to go to because like oh it's too
much that's where she met Rick and fell
in love so
do you want her on the show season 13 if
she moves to the east coast I already
texted Annie I'm with Kelly right now
I'm seeing her ring I love her I adore
if she moves to New York should be a new
housewife all right and then you you've
played matchmaker now what's your love
life situation you got a special guy you
know what I come from really fabulous
place in my life it's four years after
my divorce and I really loved me I
advise every man and every woman that
goes to a very bad breakup
you have to love yourself and surround
yourself in good friends I think I have
so many good girlfriends who got me
through this that I'm celebrating with
my birthday with 50 girlfriends at seven
o'clock at night and I got that list of
two seconds because they made you at
home and you know what if someone comes
in my life right but if they don't mix
okay - because my agenda stole well
Sonya be at this birthday celebration I
invited Sonja Dorinda
Tinsley everybody okay so not a repeat
of last year's birthday celebration
because last year was on 30 girls I
shared it with another mutual friend
Lucia so we couldn't have that many
people and I didn't host the party I'm
throwing the party Larry Scott wait
Larry Scott is going to decorate the
room I'm doing a skirt pata I took over
2,000 square foot room it's gonna be
Ramona's lounge because you know we as
women we don't like to sit down when I
should chat with everybody it's giving
so far Mona's romper room yeah
[Music]